with the announcement of a new
sponsorship scheme homes for ukraine
i'd like to thank my right honourable
friend the home secretary officials in
the home office in my own department and
across government for their work over
the course of the last days and weeks in
order to ensure that we can stand up the
scheme as quickly as possible and in
particular i would like to thank my
honorable friend richard harrington now
lord harrington of watford
his experience in ensuring that the
syrian refugee resettlement programme
was a success will prove invaluable in
making sure that we do right by the
people of ukraine
the scheme that he has helped us to
design draws on the enormous goodwill
and generosity of the british public and
our proud history of supporting the
vulnerable in their hour of greatest
need
the scheme will allow ukrainians with no
family ties to the uk to be sponsored by
individuals or organizations who can
offer them a home there will be no limit
to the number of ukrainians who can
benefit from this scheme
the scheme will be open to all ukrainian
nationals and residents they will be
able to live and work in the united
kingdom for up to three years
they will have full and unrestricted
access to benefits healthcare employment
and other support
sponsors in the uk can be of any
nationality with any immigration status
provided they have at least six months
leave to remain within the uk
sponsors will have to provide
accommodation for a minimum of six
months
and in recognition of their generosity
the government will provide a monthly
payment of 350 pounds to sponsors for
each family whom they look after
these payments will be tax-free they
will not affect benefit entitlement nor
council tax status
ukrainians arriving in the united
kingdom will also have access to the
full range of public services
doctors schools and full local
authorities support
of course we want to minimize
bureaucracy and make the process as
straightforward as possible while also
doing everything we can to ensure the
safety of all involved
sponsors will therefore be required to
undergo necessary vetting checks and
we're also streamlining processes to
security assess the status of all
ukrainians who will be arriving in the
united kingdom
from today anyone who wishes to record
their interest in sponsorship can do so
on gov dot uk and the web page has gone
live as i speak
we will then send any individual who
registers further information setting up
the next steps in this process we'll
outline what is required of a sponsor
and we will set out how sponsors can
identify a named ukrainian individual or
family who can then take up each
sponsorship offer
because we want the scheme to be up and
running as soon as possible homes for
ukraine will initially facilitate
sponsorship between people with known
connections but we will rapidly expand
the scheme in a phased way with
charities churches and community groups
to ensure that many more prospective
sponsors can be matched with ukrainians
who need help and we are of course also
working closely with the devolved
administrations to make sure that their
kind offers of help are also mobilized
i know that all concerned wants to play
their part in supporting ukrainians
who've been through so much to ensure
they feel at home in the united kingdom
i am committed to working with everyone
of goodwill to achieve this
mr speaker our country has a long and
proud history of supporting the most
vulnerable during their darkest hours
we took in refugees fleeing hitler's
germany those fleeing repression in
idiom means uganda and of course those
who fled the atrocities of the balkan
wars
more recently we've offered support to
those fleeing persecution in syria
afghanistan and hong kong
and we're doing so again with homes for
ukraine
we're a proud democracy
all of us in this house wish to see us
defend and uphold our values and stand
shoulder to shoulder with our allies and
to offer a safe haven to people who have
been forced to flee war and persecution
the british people have already opened
their hearts in so many ways i'm hopeful
that many will also be ready to open
their homes and to help those fleeing
persecution find peace healing and the
prospect of a brighter future and that
is why i commend this statement to the